meteorologists are expecting a third day
of high winds and extreme fire
conditions today in Southern California
those winds have already spread to
deadly and destructive wildfires one in
the mountains of North Los Angeles the
other about 70 miles east of the city
Errol Barnett has been in the middle of
those firefights for the past two days
and joins us this morning from the
Porter Ranch neighborhood of Los Angeles
Errol good morning good morning behind
me you're seeing one of the estimated 31
homes damaged or destroyed by what's
known as the Saddle Ridge fire it seemed
to explode with a vengeance late
Thursday evening and scorched over 7,500
acres in what is a densely populated
area just north of Los Angeles now these
fires have also claimed lives you have
one reported death here and another and
one hour east of this area wild winds
and flying embers ignited the hills
north of Los Angeles prompting
evacuations of more than a hundred
thousand people it's estimated some 31
structures have been damaged or
destroyed the fire began overnight
Thursday just behind Dona Porco's Sylmar
home so we packed up the cats and the
dog and my two sons and by the time we
did that it was fully engulfed this was
home to the Manoogian family who came to
America from Iran Serena Manoogian says
they lived here three years it
symbolized my parents hard hard work
they came here as immigrants with 45
dollars in their pockets and worked so
hard to move up to the towson man this
is what happens in Calimesa east of Los
Angeles investigators now know how the
sandalwood fire began
they say this trash truck seen in this
video shot by a passing motorist dumped
burning trash alongside a field of dry
brush I pulled up to him and I said you
can't you cannot stay here with the wind
and then the field right there you're
gonna catch everything on fire and
that's exactly what happened the fire
quickly spread and
ravage this mobile home park one person
died and at least 76 structures were
destroyed we've identified identified
the cause obviously but we're still
investigating whether or not there will
be any type of criminal charges pending
back at the Saddle Ridge fire on la's
northern edge winds died down late
Friday giving local residents a moment
to count their blessings there are no
words I can express
we're still standing our home is still
here and it's because of all of these
guys and that sentiment is reflected
just about everywhere the fire right now
is 13% contained we do expect that
number to increase later today fire
officials have lifted the mandatory
evacuation orders as well so they've
given residents about five minutes with
an escort to come home and collect some
of their belongings but here's the issue
those hot dry offshore winds that fueled
these fires initially are expected to
continue through later today so fire
officials are not taking any chances
Jericka errol thank you